hey guys how's it going so today we are
going to the Activision mocap studio now
I've been here previously you guys might
remember this little video I didn't so
the winner of that campaign is here it's
gonna be awesome
I actually am not really sure what to
expect so you guys are gonna be just as
surprised as I am security is tight so I
wanna introduce you to the winner of our
contests my name is Jason and it is look
good how are you you excited to be here
this is like a real-life video game can
you believe it yeah
you can't believe it okay cuz I can't
this is definitely my favorite part it's
like you're in a spaceship that's that
bad are you running yep that's good
how's it going - they're very bright
it's so bright
oh my gosh this is so cool
whoa yeah I'm in the printer how long
does it usually take just to print five
to six hours I know this one did
complete now time for the mocap suit I
might have to use the restroom first
because once you get in this thing you
don't want to have to deal with getting
out now the fun part
how's Emma girls look good we need to
dress up like superheroes now
I can't breathe
we've got a fine selection of you
looks great
okay we're suited up and now we're here
on the stage what do you think these
suits are very tight so what are you
expecting from this whole adventure
we're gonna fight no idea
probably some sore muscles tomorrow yeah
I remember the last time I did it we had
like a stunt girl here and she was
insane and I couldn't really move the
next day so we're gonna go easy cuz I
can't handle that here is what this
looks like from TV 133 of these tiny
reflective markers are the same thing
that you're wearing just three
millimeter versions of that we'll put a
hardened 33 all over an actor's face and
then they've done just scrape them off
and throw them out the whole process
takes about 45 minutes it's kind of like
a spa treatment sounds like a great spa
day to me right so you can choose what
kind of lens you want on this fake
virtual camera the same physical
properties as a real camera zoom dolly
pan tilt most of that being done by this
fabulous cameraman my boy soldier again
I just did a really great job of
disarming the bomb check it out
I was I was really good definitely my
best work if you can crack them on your
ring and sling them into here I can't do
that